Sharief Homsi is a standup comic in a place that's not really known for its comedy scene-- Damascus, Syria. As maybe you've heard, the place was run by a dictator for a long time, Bashar al-Assad. And back then, there were a lot of jokes that Sharief was not able to tell on stage-- definitely nothing about Assad or Assad's family, nothing about politics at all. Those kind of jokes could get you killed or disappeared into one of Assad's infamous prisons. So during those years, Sharief kept jokes like that in a folder on his computer labeled "Lebanon." Because he pretty much only felt safe telling them when he would take trips abroad.
沙里夫·霍姆西（Sharief Homsi）是一位脱口秀喜剧演员，身处一个并非以喜剧氛围闻名的地方——叙利亚大马士革。正如你可能听说的那样，这个地方长期由独裁者巴沙尔·阿萨德（Bashar al-Assad）统治。在那个时期，沙里夫有很多笑话是不能在舞台上讲的——绝对不能涉及阿萨德本人或其家族，也不能谈论任何政治内容。那样的笑话可能会让你丧命，或者让你“消失”在阿萨德臭名昭著的监狱里。因此，在那几年里，沙里夫把这些笑话保存在电脑里一个标为“黎巴嫩”的文件夹中，因为他觉得只有在出国旅行时讲这些笑话才比较安全。
There is one joke. Well, I love this joke. I want to bring it back. But there is one joke I used to say when I go to Lebanon. Like, listen, we have a lot of problems, but you don't have a president. And our problem is that we have one. So maybe if you take him, and you can rent him for a bit, and if you like him, you can keep him.
有一个笑话。好吧，我非常喜欢这个笑话。我想把它重新拿出来讲。但有一个笑话是我去黎巴嫩时常讲的，比如：“听着，我们有很多问题，但你们没有总统。而我们的问题是，我们有一个。所以，也许你们可以把他带走，租用一阵子；如果你们喜欢，那就可以留下他。”
You cannot say anything like this, man. That joke, if I say it over here, we will get killed. There is no joke with them.
你不能说任何类似的话，伙计。那个笑话，如果我在这里讲，我们会被杀掉的。和他们没什么笑话可讲的。
Bashar al-Assad's family ruled Syria for 53 years, the last 13 of which were a brutal civil war. Over 300,000 Syrian civilians died. Then, a year ago, to everybody's surprise, a bunch of rebel groups overthrew the regime in just 12 days. Assad, his wife, Asma, and their family flew to Russia. The rebels were led by an Islamist group called Hay'at Tahrir al-Sham, HTS for short.
巴沙尔·阿萨德的家族统治了叙利亚53年，最后13年是一场残酷的内战。超过30万叙利亚平民死亡。然后，一年前，出乎所有人意料，一群反政府武装在短短12天内推翻了政权。阿萨德、他的妻子阿斯玛（Asma）以及他们的家人飞往了俄罗斯。反政府武装由一个名为“沙姆解放组织”（Hay'at Tahrir al-Sham，简称HTS）的伊斯兰组织领导。
And then the new people in power surprised everybody again by not immediately becoming another repressive regime. HTS leader Ahmad al-Sharaa says he's acting as interim president and has promised to hold elections in the next few years. And Syrians have been experiencing a freedom that they have not experienced before. I had dinner a couple weeks ago with somebody who was just there, and they were talking about how kind of inspiring it is to be there right now. She met lots of people who were moving back, ready and excited to rebuild their country.
随后，新的当权者再次让所有人感到惊讶，他们没有立即变成另一个高压政权。HTS领导人艾哈迈德·沙拉（Ahmad al-Sharaa）表示，他正担任临时总统，并承诺在未来几年内举行选举。叙利亚人正在经历一种他们以前从未体验过的自由。几周前，我和一位刚从那里回来的人共进晚餐，他们谈到了现在身处那里是多么令人振奋。她遇到了许多正在搬回家乡的人，他们已经准备好并迫不及待地想要重建自己的国家。
But at the same time, parts of Syria are still violent. There was fighting this month in and around Aleppo. Over 150,000 people were displaced. In July, Sharief had to cancel a show in a city called Suwayda because of a massacre there. 800 people were killed.
但与此同时，叙利亚部分地区仍然暴力频发。本月阿勒颇及其周边地区发生了战斗。超过15万人流离失所。七月，沙里夫不得不取消在苏韦达（Suwayda）市的一场演出，因为那里发生了一场大屠杀，造成800人死亡。
And then in October, in the middle of this chaos and hope, Sharief and the other comedians in his comedy group-- the group is called "Styria"-- decided to go on tour. They planned 16 cities in 21 days all over Syria-- in conservative regions, in liberal areas like Damascus, areas under Kurdish control, in areas that were once under ISIS control. And they really weren't sure how this was going to go. Nobody had ever done this.
接着在十月，在这混乱与希望并存的时刻，沙里夫和他的喜剧团体“Styria”的其他成员决定去巡演。他们计划在21天内走遍叙利亚的16个城市——包括保守地区、像大马士革这样的自由地区、库尔德人控制的地区，以及曾经在ISIS控制下的地区。他们确实不确定这会进展得如何。从来没有人这样做过。
And-- this is the tricky part-- under the dictator, it was clear what they could not say on stage. But now, there seemed to be no rulebook at all. If anything, the new government was saying, go ahead, you can make jokes about us. We're different from the old regime. But the comedians didn't know if they could trust that.
而且——棘手的部分在于——在独裁者统治下，他们很清楚哪些不能在舞台上说。但现在，似乎完全没有规则手册。如果有的话，新政府一直在说，来吧，你们可以拿我们开玩笑。我们和旧政权不同。但喜剧演员们不知道是否能信任这一点。
And then beyond that, there are lots of just very conservative, very religious people around Syria. Some of them are figures of authority in towns and provinces. The comedians wondered how they would react to things that they heard on stage. They worried about random hotheads hearing about them and things they said, deciding to show up with a gun. Even before they left, they got death threats in their DMs, stuff like--
除此之外，叙利亚各地还有许多非常保守、非常虔诚的人。他们中的一些人是城镇和省份的权威人物。喜剧演员们好奇他们会对舞台上听到的内容作何反应。他们担心随意的狂热分子会听到关于他们及其言论的消息，然后决定带枪出现。甚至在他们出发之前，他们就在私信中收到了死亡威胁，比如——
If you ever talk about the revolution, we're going to come kill you one by one, and we'll-- blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
如果你敢谈论革命，我们会一个一个把你杀了，我们会……巴拉巴拉巴拉。
These messages freaked Sharief out, but he got where they were coming from. The country's been through 13 years of war. He and most of the other comedians are from Damascus, a city that saw the least of the fighting because it was controlled by the regime. By Syrian standards, they're the soft liberals.
这些信息让沙里夫感到恐慌，但他理解他们的立场。这个国家经历了13年的战争。他和大多数其他喜剧演员都来自大马士革，这座城市因受政权控制而受到的战斗影响最小。按照叙利亚的标准，他们属于温和的自由派。
I understand because some people, man, they see what we do as a luxury.
我理解，因为有些人，伙计，他们把我们做的事情看作是一种奢侈。
My house was destroyed. And my brother was dead. My mother was dead. And you hear in Damascus were having fun. You didn't have anything wrong. And you are going to make people laugh.
我的房子被毁了，我的兄弟死了，我的母亲也死了。而你听说在大马士革的人们正在享乐。你们什么损失都没有，还要让人发笑。
This is like luxury, you know? So they cannot take the joke. And I understand. They have the right to be sad.
这就像是奢侈，你知道吗？所以他们无法接受这个笑话。我理解。他们有权感到悲伤。
Any comedy show in Syria right now for everybody-- comedians, the audience-- they're all figuring out what's OK to say out loud. Ayman Oghanna, a reporter based in Damascus, heard about all this, and he also was very curious to see what the comedians could get away with, and whether they would even get all the way through the tour. He hung out with them on tour for two weeks on long van rides across Syria, backstage at their shows. Lots of stuff ended up happening, stuff, I think it's safe to say, they did not see coming.
目前在叙利亚的任何喜剧表演——对所有人，包括演员和观众——大家都在摸索什么可以公开说。驻扎在大马士革的记者艾曼·奥汉纳（Ayman Oghanna）听说了这一切，他也非常好奇这些喜剧演员能做到什么程度，以及他们是否能完成整场巡演。他在两周的巡演中一直与他们在一起，坐在穿越叙利亚的长途面包车里，待在演出后台。结果发生了很多事情，我想可以肯定地说，这些都是他们没预料到的。
From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. We hit the road with these comedians today. And with that introduction, here's Ayman with Act One, an act we're calling "Too Soon?"
来自芝加哥WBEZ广播电台，这里是《This American Life》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天我们跟随这些喜剧演员踏上旅程。在这一介绍之后，下面请艾曼带来第一幕，我们将这一幕称为“为时尚早？”（Too Soon?）
I meet up with the comedians in Safita, a city about three hours drive north of Damascus. They're in a shared apartment that doubles as a green room. The venue owner let them all crash for free. There are several mattresses to a room, suitcases under the beds, and the comics are walking in and out of rooms, getting ready and telling jokes to warm up.
我在萨菲塔（Safita）与喜剧演员们会合，这是一座距离大马士革以北约三小时车程的城市。他们住在一个兼作化妆室的合租公寓里。场地主人让他们免费借住。房间里有好几张床垫，床底下放着行李箱，喜剧演员们在房间进进出出，准备演出并讲笑话热身。
Hello.
你好。
Hey, Malke.
嘿，马尔克（Malke）。
I need to get naked.
我得脱衣服了。
No worries.
没关系。
No, no, no!
不，不，不！
Malke Is Malke Mardinali, one of the founders of the group, along with Sharief.
马尔克是马尔克·马尔迪纳利（Malke Mardinali），是该团体与沙里夫共同的创始人之一。
You can ask him anything while he's dressing.
你可以在他穿衣服的时候问他任何问题。
OK, Malke, while you're dressing, I'm going to ask you the same question I just asked Sharief.
好的，马尔克，趁你在换衣服，我要问你刚才问沙里夫的那个问题。
Ask.
问吧。
Is there a joke you're thinking of saying tonight that you're not sure if you want to say it, that might be a bit dangerous?
有没有什么笑话是你今晚想讲但又不确定是否要讲的，可能会有点危险？
Actually, there was a few, but a few minutes ago, we were speaking about it. Here, the audience is new to this kind of art, you know? So I don't want any joke to be uncomfortable for them, you know? So I'm going safe side this time.
其实有几个，但几分钟前我们还在讨论这个问题。在这里，观众对这种艺术还很陌生，你知道吗？所以我不想让任何笑话让他们感到不舒服。所以我这次选了稳妥的路线。
I feel if I say something on the government, it would be a little bit dangerous. They will not feel comfortable. Something like this. For the sensitivity of this place, not because we can't say it, you know? But here, I don't know how they will react to it.
我觉得如果我讲一些关于政府的事情，会有点危险。他们会感到不自在，大概是这样。这是基于这个地方的敏感性，并不是说我们不能讲，你知道吗？但我不知道他们会作何反应。
And what is the joke you're not sure about telling?
那你不确定要讲的那个笑话是什么？
[SIGHS] Maybe something about how the Ministry of Defense dress. They don't wear shoes. They only wear the flip-flops, you know? Fuh fuh fuh! That's how they fight. [LAUGHS] I feel something like this. It's a lot dangerous to see someone's feets in a war, you know?
[叹气] 也许是关于国防部官员的穿着。他们不穿鞋，只穿人字拖，你知道吗？福、福、福！他们就是这样战斗的。[笑] 我觉得像这样的东西。在战争中看到某人的脚是挺危险的，你知道吗？
This is actually a joke about the current government, that they were such a ragtag army that they came to power in flip-flops. Comedy and poetry are probably the hardest things to translate from any language.
这实际上是一个关于现任政府的笑话，讽刺他们是一支如此乌合之众的军队，以至于穿着人字拖就上台执政了。喜剧和诗歌可能是任何语言中最难翻译的东西。
I swear to God in Arabic it's very funny. Just anyone is hearing us right now, it is funny in Arabic. You should learn Arabic, and come and watch the show.
我向上帝发誓，这个笑话在阿拉伯语里非常搞笑。任何正在听我们节目的人，它在阿拉伯语里确实很有趣。你应该学学阿拉伯语，然后来看我们的演出。
Malke plays it safe that night in Safita. He skips the flip-flop joke.
马尔克那天晚上在萨菲塔采取了稳妥做法。他跳过了人字拖的笑话。
Styria is a small crew, around 20 comics. Two of them are women. Some still keep their day jobs. There's a dentist, a university lecturer, an engineer, students. They are mostly in their 20s and 30s. The group's name, Styria, is a combination of "Syria" plus "hysteria," because that's what it felt like to laugh in Syria when the group got together three years ago-- a manic release.
Styria是一个由大约20名喜剧演员组成的小团队。其中有两名女性。有些人还有全职工作。有牙医、大学讲师、工程师和学生。他们大多在20多岁和30多岁。团名“Styria”是将“Syria”（叙利亚）和“hysteria”（歇斯底里）组合在一起，因为三年前当这个团体聚在一起时，在叙利亚大笑就是这种感觉——一种狂躁的宣泄。
Sharief and Malke do this full-time. Sharief is the group's spiritual leader, the one who used to have a folder labeled "Lebanon." He's got a laid-back stoner vibe, covered in tattoos, light beard, 33 years old.
沙里夫和马尔克是全职做这个的。沙里夫是该团体的精神领袖，就是那个曾经拥有标着“黎巴嫩”文件夹的人。他有一种慵懒的嬉皮士气质，满身纹身，留着浅浅的胡须，今年33岁。
Malke is the one running the tour. He's 29 years old, with dark hair and a cheeky grin. He's the Paul McCartney to Sharief's John Lennon, more tightly wound. He's the fixer, lining up venues, negotiating with government officials, driving the van, keeping track of permits, schedules, and constantly updating the list of things that could go wrong. He worries out loud, cracks jokes as he does it, a kind of nervous humor that makes it clear he's holding the whole operation together. He actually thinks they're going to be fine on this tour.
马尔克是负责巡演运营的人。他29岁，深色头发，带着顽皮的微笑。他就像沙里夫的约翰·列侬对应出的保罗·麦卡特尼，更加紧绷。他是协调员，负责联系场地、与政府官员谈判、开面包车、追踪许可和时间表，并不断更新可能出错的事情清单。他会大声地担忧，同时边开玩笑边解决问题，这种紧张的幽默感表明他正在维持整个运作。他其实认为这次巡演会很顺利。
I don't think something bad will happen to us. Because nobody cares about us, yanni. Let's state the obvious. Nobody cares about who the fuck we are. I'm not like a superstar. I'm not George Clooney on the tour. I'm Malke. He's Sharief. That's Khalid. That's Azez.
我不认为我们会出什么事。因为没人关心我们，雅尼（yanni）。让我们直说吧。根本没人关心我们到底是谁。我不是什么超级巨星。我不是巡演中的乔治·克鲁尼。我是马尔克。他是沙里夫。那是哈立德。那是阿泽兹。
Nobody cares about us. Nothing bad will happen to us. A few people telling some jokes-- [CLICKS TONGUE] let them.
没人关心我们。我们不会出什么事的。几个人讲些笑话——[咂舌]让他们去吧。
But there are two stops on the tour he's worried about.
但这次巡演中有两站让他感到担心。
I'm most scared of Aleppo and Hama. Aleppo and Hama, those two cities are very dangerous-- very dangerous. Oof, man. Oof. So we have to be careful dealing with-- I don't know with them-- the mind. I don't know what-- it's the term. Al-Ghaam. Al-Ghaam.
我最怕阿勒颇和哈马。阿勒颇和哈马，那两个城市非常危险——非常危险。哎呀，伙计。哎呀。所以我们必须小心处理——我不知道该怎么说——他们的心思。我不知道那个词——雷区。雷区。
Minefield.
雷区。
Minefield, yes, yes. So it's a minefield in Hama.
对，雷区。哈马就是一个雷区。
Hama is a conservative city, stop 7 on the tour. Aleppo is stop 9, a city divided by different factions. Before they could go on the tour, Malke had to sign what he translates as an obligation with the Ministry of Tourism, a pledge to avoid certain jokes. Unlike during the old Assad regime, they're allowed to make fun of the current leaders.
哈马是一个保守的城市，是巡演的第7站。阿勒颇是第9站，一座被不同派系分裂的城市。在开始巡演之前，马尔克必须与旅游部签署一份他所说的“义务书”，承诺避免某些笑话。与旧的阿萨德政权时期不同，他们被允许取笑现任领导人。
The pledge is a promise not to use hate speech and to avoid jokes that could rile people up and cause civil unrest, like jokes about religion. It's a written commitment tied to the permit. If they breach it, the Ministry of Tourism can cancel the show or penalize the group.
这份承诺书保证不使用仇恨言论，避免可能会煽动民众并引起内乱的笑话，比如涉及宗教的笑话。这是一种与许可挂钩的书面承诺。如果他们违背，旅游部可以取消演出或对团队进行惩罚。
The first four shows go pretty smoothly, playing in mostly liberal towns where they didn't expect problems. One gets oversold because the app they use to sell tickets malfunctions, which is a huge pain in the ass. But mostly, it's sold-out rooms. So far, so good.
前四场演出进行得相当顺利，主要是在那些他们没预料到会有问题的自由城镇进行。其中一场因为售票APP故障导致超卖，这简直让人头疼。但总的来说，场场爆满。到目前为止，一切都好。
Stop 5 on the tour, Latakia, a sunny port city with a beachfront and blue Mediterranean waters. Fish restaurants and clubs line the shore. It's been called the Miami of Syria. And it would be, except for what happened here last March, when sectarian violence killed around 1,500 people. That's the stage the comedians are walking into tonight-- fun, but tense.
巡演第5站是拉塔基亚（Latakia），一个阳光明媚的港口城市，有海滩和湛蓝的地中海海水。海边排满了鱼餐厅和俱乐部。它被称为“叙利亚的迈阿密”。如果不是去年三月发生在这里的事情，它确实会是那样——当时宗派暴力杀害了大约1500人。这就是喜剧演员们今晚要面对的舞台——有趣，但紧张。
OK, it's Wednesday, the 15th of October. We're in Latakia. We're just arriving at the venue to see Sharief, Malke, and the guys as they set up. It's a beautiful venue overlooking the sea.
好的，现在是10月15日，星期三。我们在拉塔基亚。我们刚到达场地看沙里夫、马尔克和伙计们进行布置。这是一个俯瞰大海的漂亮场地。
[CLAPS] My friend! Hello, welcome, welcome.
[鼓掌] 我的朋友！你好，欢迎，欢迎。
Hi, Ayman. Hi, how are you? How are you?
嗨，艾曼。嗨，你好吗？你好吗？
Good. What's happening?
很好。发生什么事了？
We're preparing for the show.
我们正在准备演出。
Sharief is unloading equipment and making sure everything is in place, working. Malke's putting up posters and banners at the entrance.
沙里夫正在卸下设备并确保一切就位、运作正常。马尔克正在入口处张贴海报和横幅。
I told you, we're the logistic. We're the reservation. We are the comedian. We are the management. We are the president of Syria.
我告诉过你，我们就是后勤。我们就是预订。我们就是喜剧演员。我们就是管理层。我们就是叙利亚总统。
We are Styria.
我们是Styria。
The same-- we are Styria. So we're preparing the show, and we just learned we might have-- we cannot do our show in Hama.
一样——我们是Styria。所以我们正在准备演出，刚才得知我们可能——我们不能在哈马演出了。
Hama, one of the cities Malke was worried about.
哈马，马尔克担心的城市之一。
Man, this is insane. This is insane. This is crazy. Oh! [LAUGHS]
伙计，这太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。这简直疯了。噢！[笑]
You're pissed off.
你很生气。
Yeah, yeah, very, very man. Very angry about it.
是的，是的，非常，伙计。非常生气。
They had gotten a call from their fixer in Hama, the guy setting up their show there. He said he had gone to pay the fees for the show, but was told the local government in Hama wasn't going to allow it.
他们接到了哈马协调人的电话，就是那个帮他们安排演出的人。他说他去缴纳演出费用时，被告知哈马当地政府不允许举办。
Because we got a report that we are-- this is a new one. Prepare.
因为我们收到一份报告，说我们正在——这是一个新的说法。准备好听吧。
It's fresh.
很新鲜。
It's a fresh-- we are supporting the gay rights in Syria or in Hama.
这很新鲜——我们支持叙利亚或哈马的同性恋权利。
Why?
为什么？
We don't know. Like, the one who is preparing the venue in Hama, they sent him to the--
我们不知道。比如，那个准备哈马场地的人，他们把他叫去——
They are assuming. We didn't say anything about this kind of topic, ever!
他们是主观臆测。我们从来没有说过任何关于这个话题的内容！
Malke talked to the guy in the government. Tell him, bro, this is really offensive. If you tell me I'm threatening the people, the religion, anything, I'm talking against politics, I understand. But gay rights-- why? Like, when? [INAUDIBLE] So we don't know--
马尔克和那个政府的人谈了。告诉他，兄弟，这真的很冒犯人。如果你说我威胁到人民、宗教或任何东西，我在反对政治，我能理解。但同性恋权利——为什么？像是，什么时候？[听不清] 所以我们不知道——
How? Who? Too much W's.
怎么回事？谁？这太多“为什么”了。
The Styria comedians can talk about whatever they want in their sets. Their only rule is no hate speech. But still, nobody campaigns for any rights of any kind in their shows.
Styria的喜剧演员们可以在他们的演出中谈论任何他们想谈论的话题。他们唯一的规则是没有仇恨言论。但即便如此，也没有人在表演中为任何类型的权利进行过宣传。
Just imagine like you cannot think about supporting any rights, like, you see, gay rights, vegetarian rights, any rights. So the idea, we don't know, man.
想象一下，你不能考虑支持任何权利，你看，同性恋权利、素食者权利，任何权利。所以这个想法，我们不知道，伙计。
They care about Hama because it's symbolic. A full house in a town with a conservative reputation-- a real test of what they can or can't say in the new Syria. They weren't even going to play Hama when they planned the tour. Too conservative, too many ways it could go wrong.
他们在乎哈马是因为它具有象征意义。在一个名声保守的城镇满座——这是对他们在新叙利亚能说什么、不能说什么的真正考验。在计划巡演时，他们甚至没打算去哈马。太保守了，出错的可能性太多。
This is the place where, in 1982, Hafez al-Assad, Bashar's father, crushed the Muslim Brotherhood uprising. Thousands were killed. Many disappeared. People there still carry that history. It shapes what you can say in a room.
这是1982年哈菲兹·阿萨德（巴沙尔的父亲）镇压穆斯林兄弟会起义的地方。数千人死亡。许多人消失了。那里的人们仍然背负着那段历史。它塑造了你能在房间里说些什么。
But then a fan of the group DMed Sharief, begging him to come. We like you here. We want you here. We want to change the conservative stereotype of our city. So Sharief said, OK, fuck it, let's do Hama. They figured if they could play Hama, it could open the doors to other conservative cities, too. And they sold out the Hama show, 230 tickets.
但后来，该团体的一位粉丝在私信里恳求沙里夫一定要去。我们这里喜欢你们。我们想要你们来。我们想改变我们城市保守的刻板印象。所以沙里夫说，好吧，去他妈的，去哈马。他们认为如果能在哈马演出，就能打开通往其他保守城市的大门。而且哈马场的票卖光了，230张票。
It's Wednesday. The Hama show is supposed to happen Monday. So Malke calls the guy in charge of culture in Hama, a local bureaucrat he calls the sheikh, to convince the sheikh to not cancel the show.
今天是星期三。哈马演出原定于周一举行。所以马尔克打电话给哈马负责文化的人，一个当地官僚，他称之为“谢赫”（sheikh），想要说服谢赫不要取消演出。
I am beyond worried right now. My mind in Hama.
我现在极其担忧。我的心思全在哈马。
That night, they still have a show to do.
那天晚上，他们还得继续演出。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[讲阿拉伯语]
It's a simple format-- six comedians, seven minutes each. The room is full, maybe 200, 300 people. Malke opens the show. He asks the audience not to take videos or photos or post on social media because they just got in trouble with the government for promoting homosexuality.
这是一种简单的形式——六名喜剧演员，每人七分钟。房间里坐满了人，大概200到300人。马尔克开启了演出。他要求观众不要拍摄视频或照片，也不要发布到社交媒体上，因为他们刚因为宣扬同性恋而惹上了政府。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[讲阿拉伯语]
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Malke tells a version of the flip-flop joke, how security forces have been fighting for 14 years, but keep their toes out. It gets a big laugh. Then he hands the mic over to Sharief.
马尔克讲了一个人字拖笑话的版本，关于安全部队战斗了14年，却总是露出脚趾。这引起了大笑。然后他把麦克风交给了沙里夫。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[讲阿拉伯语]
[APPLAUSE, CHEERING]
[掌声，欢呼]
Sharief tells a joke that definitely would have gotten him into trouble under the Assad regime. It shows you how much things have changed in Syria this last year. It's about Asma al-Assad, the dictator's wife, who had breast cancer. Technically, it's about her bra.
沙里夫讲了一个在阿萨德政权下绝对会让他惹上麻烦的笑话。这显示了叙利亚过去一年发生了多大变化。那是关于独裁者的妻子阿斯玛·阿萨德的，她曾患有乳腺癌。严格来说，是关于她的胸罩的。
Here's the setup. December 8, 2024, the Assads flee for Russia. Syrians go to the abandoned presidential palace to loot it, taking little trophies, souvenirs.
背景是这样的：2024年12月8日，阿萨德一家逃往俄罗斯。叙利亚人闯进被遗弃的总统府进行搜刮，带走了一些小奖杯和纪念品。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[讲阿拉伯语]
So in that joke, I say people went to Bashar al-Assad to steal some watches, some expensive painting. Me, I go, what I get? Asma al-Assad's bra.
所以在这个笑话里，我说人们去巴沙尔·阿萨德家里偷手表、昂贵的画作。我呢，我去了，我得到了什么？阿斯玛·阿萨德的胸罩。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[讲阿拉伯语]
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
[LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE]
[笑声，掌声]
And I have it one piece.
而且我只拿到了一半。
He holds up half of a bra. The other half is missing.
他举起半个胸罩。另一半不见了。
Because she got one breast taken because she had cancer. And people start to laugh and feel shy. And I say, hey, hey, don't feel sorry about her. She have cancer. Feel sorry for the cancer. He have Asma al-Assad.
因为她因患癌症切除了一侧乳房。人们开始笑，又感到羞涩。我说，嘿，嘿，别为她感到难过。她有癌症。应该为癌症感到难过，它才真的患上了“阿斯玛·阿萨德”。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[讲阿拉伯语]
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And people are just like, ah! I love this joke.
人们就像是，啊！我喜欢这个笑话。
Biggest laugh of the night. Afterwards, I talked to a few members of the audience.
当晚笑声最热烈的时候。之后，我和几位观众谈了谈。
How was the show tonight?
今晚演出怎么样？
Tremendous, extraordinary. I haven't witnessed anything the same in my life.
极好，非凡。我这辈子没见过这样的演出。
It was amazing. It was unbelievable. It's-- no one expected this. They say things that you cannot say, especially in Latakia. They're amazing.
太棒了。令人难以置信。没有人预料到这一点。他们说了一些你绝对不能说的话，尤其是在拉塔基亚。他们太棒了。
One guy said he was depressed before the show.
一个人说他在演出前感到很抑郁。
But after five minutes in the show, I felt myself like flying in the night sky.
但在演出五分钟后，我觉得自己像是飞在夜空里。
The only criticism I heard was that they were not political enough.
我听到的唯一批评是他们谈论政治还不够多。
I would like to hear more about politics. Because the more you talk about politics, the more you are free. I don't think that in the coming years, they will be able to mention the same jokes. I don't believe that they are going to be free like this. I feel that Syria now is going to be like the Assad period.
我想听更多关于政治的。因为你谈论政治越多，你就越自由。我不认为在未来的几年里，他们还能讲出同样的笑话。我不相信他们还能像现在这样自由。我觉得叙利亚现在又要变回阿萨德时期了。
Some Syrians have told me that they feel as though they're speaking on borrowed time. They're happy the old regime is gone, but are unsure about the future. Syrians are setting precedents for what can be said, post by post, room by room.
一些叙利亚人告诉我，他们感觉自己是在借来的时间里说话。他们很高兴旧政权倒台了，但对未来感到不确定。叙利亚人正在逐条、逐个房间地开创什么可以说的新先例。
But maybe it's a bubble. They can joke for now, but there's real trepidation about what comes next. By the end of the night, the comedians haven't heard back from the sheikh. The fate of the Hama show is still on the line.
但也许这是一个泡沫。他们现在可以开玩笑，但对接下来会发生什么有着真正的恐惧。到了晚上结束时，喜剧演员们还没收到谢赫的消息。哈马演出的命运依然悬而未决。
Ayman Oghanna. Coming up, the comedians head into Hama province, the sheikh's province. And the sheikh brings all the boys to the yard-- figuratively, I mean. Stay with us.
我是艾曼·奥汉纳。接下来，喜剧演员们将前往哈马省，那个谢赫的省份。而谢赫把所有人都叫到了院子里——我是指比喻意义上的。请留在我们身边。
It's This American Life. If you've just tuned in, reporter Ayman Oghanna hit the road with a group of Syrian comedians on their first nationwide tour since the Assad regime fell a year ago. We have arrived at "Act Two, The Drama in Hama." Here's Ayman.
这里是《This American Life》。如果你刚调入频道，记者艾曼·奥汉纳跟随一群叙利亚喜剧演员进行了自阿萨德政权一年前倒台以来的首次全国巡演。我们已经来到了“第二幕，哈马的戏码”。下面请艾曼继续。
The comedians have a two-day break after Latakia, so they go back to Damascus to recuperate. They still don't know what's going to happen with their show in Hama. I meet up with them at Sharief's place in Damascus, his family's house. It's big, in a nice leafy neighborhood.
在拉塔基亚演出后，喜剧演员们有两天的休息时间，所以他们回大马士革恢复体力。他们仍然不知道哈马的演出会发生什么。我在大马士革沙里夫的家里见到他们，那是他父母的房子。房子很大，在一个漂亮、绿树成荫的街区。
How are you feeling?
你感觉如何？
Oof, tired. I need a massage, Ayman.
哎呀，累死了。我需要按摩，艾曼。
Sharief's parents are drinking tea in the living room with his aunt and uncle.
沙里夫的父母正在客厅里和他的姑姑、姑父喝茶。
[INAUDIBLE] This is my place. This is my room. This is my family, my uncle. This is his wife.
[听不清] 这是我的地方。这是我的房间。这是我的家人，我姑父。这是他妻子。
[ARABIC] Hi.
[阿拉伯语] 嗨。
We step into Sharief's bedroom, the operating base for Styria. Malke, Sharief, and Omar, another founding comedian, have all kicked off their shoes and are drinking coffee and discussing what's to come. They are waiting for the sheikh to call with an update on Hama. Malke's phone stays face up on the table.
我们走进沙里夫的卧室，那是Styria的指挥基地。马尔克、沙里夫和另一个创始人喜剧演员奥马尔都脱掉了鞋子，正在喝咖啡讨论未来的去向。他们正在等谢赫打来电话告知哈马的最新消息。马尔克的手机正面朝上放在桌子上。
Psychedelic stoner posters are taped to the wall. A desktop computer obscures the window. A few childish pictures sit on the mantle. Malke points to them-- a Harry Potter poster and a painting made by a small child.
墙上贴着迷幻的嬉皮士海报。一台台式电脑挡住了窗户。壁炉架上放着几张充满童趣的照片。马尔克指着它们——一张哈利波特海报和一幅小孩画的画。
That's from Karim al-Assad room, the sons of Bashar.
那是从卡里姆·阿萨德（Karim al-Assad）房间拿来的，巴沙尔的儿子。
Oh, wow. So this is taken from the palace?
哇。所以这是从总统府拿来的？
Yes.
是的。
Yeah. And I have a few stuff also from his house. What we get also, Malke? I get from his house, I took shitty stuff, not something with the-- it value to me more than at value in the real world, you know? Because that day was magnificent, man. Yeah, yeah.
是的，我还从他家拿了些别的东西。我们还拿了什么，马尔克？我从他家拿了一些破烂，对我来说它的价值远超真实世界里的价值，你知道吗？因为那天真是太壮观了，伙计。那天我……是的，是的。
I say this in my standup. I said, I really hope we don't have to feel this feeling again, of us getting liberated. Because in order to feel it again, another dictator would have to come.
我在脱口秀里讲过这个。我说，我真心希望我们不必再经历那种被解放的感觉。因为要再次感受到它，就意味着会有另一个独裁者出现。
So in that day, I felt totally free. It was total chaos, man. Like, I spent from 6 o'clock until 6:00 at the evening, I was outside in the road with my friend celebrating. We went to al-Assad home. You see, I have his bra, his painting, and stuff. We went to the parliament, to the Ministry of Defense.
所以那天，我感到完全自由。那简直是一片混乱，伙计。我从早上6点一直到晚上6点都在街上，和我的朋友们庆祝。我们去了阿萨德家。你看，我有他的胸罩、他的画之类的。我们去了议会、国防部。
His bra?
他的胸罩？
His wife--
他妻子的——
So that's really his wife's bra?
所以那真的是他妻子的胸罩？
Yeah.
是的。
You're not kidding?
你不是在开玩笑吧？
Yeah, I'm not kidding. I brought shitty stuff for me. I have-- and the half of the bra. I give it to my girlfriend, my ex-girlfriend. Because--
是的，我没开玩笑。我拿了一些破玩意儿。我有……还有那一半胸罩。我把它给了我女朋友，我的前女友。因为——
I thought you were joking. That's--
我以为你在开玩笑。那真是——
No, no, man. It's a real shit. I turned it into a joke. Let me show you. [INAUDIBLE] Let me show you the book of my standup comedy when I was inside.
不，不，伙计。是真的。我把它变成了一个笑话。让我给你看看。[听不清] 让我给你看看我关在里面时写的脱口秀剧本。
When Sharief says he was inside, he means prison. Sharief was jailed in Dubai for a little more than three years, from 2018 to 2021. He hands me a paperback book with a worn cover.
当沙里夫说他在里面时，他指的是监狱。沙里夫在迪拜被关了三年多，从2018年到2021年。他递给我一本封面破旧的平装书。
So this was with me in the inside. See what I write.
这本书陪我度过了监狱生活。看看我写的。
Be a Great Standup is the name of the book. Oh, wow. It's covered in handwritten notes.
书名是《成为伟大的脱口秀演员》。噢，哇。上面写满了手写笔记。
Yeah.
是的。
This is your notes?
这是你的笔记？
This is my notes. This is me writing standup in the inside.
这是我的笔记。这是我在里面写脱口秀内容时记下的。
So you're inside your cell, just reading about comedy and writing in this book?
所以你在牢房里，只是在读关于喜剧的书，并在上面写写画画？
Yeah. Yeah, I can show you. I can show you a book where I writed what I want to do when I'm going to go out.
是的。我可以给你看，我写了一本书，记录了我出去后想做的事情。
So this is a notepad you had in prison?
所以这是一个你在监狱里用的笔记本？
Yeah. Yeah, and you can see in English, I say a new laptop, writing, and standup comedy. And I write here some gem-- "never, never speak the plan."
是的，你可以在英文部分看到，我写着“买新电脑、写作、脱口秀”。我在这里写了一些精华——“永远，永远不要说出计划”。
What's "never, never speak the plan"?
什么是“永远不要说出计划”？
I used to talk a lot, man. This is what got me into shit.
我以前话太多了，伙计。这就是让我陷入困境的原因。
This shit is a narcotics charge. Sharief was dealing drugs in Dubai and got caught by the authorities.
困境指的是毒品指控。沙里夫在迪拜贩毒时被当局抓获。
I got greedy, and I got caught by a kameen, by an ambush. And they gave me marked money, and it was all a play and all a game. I was the one who burned.
我贪心了，被一个伏击（kameen）抓住了。他们给了我标记过的钱，这一切都是个局。我是那个被烧掉的人。
According to court documents, Sharief sold drugs to an undercover cop. A snitch had tipped off the police. He was arrested and given a life sentence, which, in the UAE, is a common penalty for drug offenses, no matter how small. He says he got out because his father wrote a mercy petition, a letter to the prosecutor begging to let him go.
根据法庭文件，沙里夫卖毒品给了一名卧底警察。一名线人向警方举报了他。他被捕并被判终身监禁，在阿联酋，这是毒品犯罪的常见处罚，无论数额大小。他说他能出来是因为他父亲写了一份求情信，请求检察官放过他。
My name was 71. It was 70 people who meant to go out, and they added my name after three years and three months. And--
我的名字排在第71位。本来有70个人要出去，他们三年三个月后把我的名字加了进去。然后——
Thank God. And then you came out, and you were like, I know what I want to do. I'm going to be a comedian.
感谢上帝。然后你出来了，心想：“我知道我想做什么了。我要成为一名喜剧演员。”
Actually, the first year, I was an animal.
事实上，第一年，我像个动物。
What do you mean?
什么意思？
You know, your basic-- I want to eat, I want to have sex, I want to hear some music. It was taken from me. And after nine months, I was going into then the same cycle that got me into jail.
你知道，你基本的欲望……我想吃东西，我想做爱，我想听点音乐。这些都被剥夺了。九个月后，我又陷入了让我进监狱的同一个循环。
A friend called him out for how he was acting. Sharief said enough and broke the cycle by focusing on saving money for his comedy dream, taking any job he could.
一个朋友对他当时的行为提出了批评。沙里夫清醒了过来，通过专注于赚钱实现喜剧梦想打破了循环，他做了任何能做的工作。
And when that happened, everything started to happen. Like, someone asked me to do standup comedy between parties and stuff, and I was like, I want to do this.
当这一切发生时，事情就开始了。有人请我在派对间隙表演脱口秀，我就想：我想做这个。
And I thought, is it possible in all Syria, in all the dark humor and shit we have, I am the only one in Syria or Damascus that want to do standup comedy? Just let me put the news out and see who are interested. I needed a team so I can start. So we can do something.
我想，在叙利亚，在所有我们经历的黑色幽默和狗屁倒灶的事情里，我是叙利亚或大马士革唯一想做脱口秀的人吗？只要让我发布消息，看看谁感兴趣。我需要一个团队来开始。这样我们就能做点什么。
That's how he met Malke. They both grew up in Damascus. Sharief is Muslim. Malke is Christian. They had mutual friends, but didn't know each other. Malke was working in a bank at the time. But they both dreamt of being standup comedians. Here's Sharief.
这就是他遇到马尔克的方式。他们都在大马士革长大。沙里夫是穆斯林。马尔克是基督徒。他们有共同的朋友，但并不认识。马尔克当时在银行工作。但他们都有成为脱口秀演员的梦想。听听沙里夫怎么说。
Someone sent me his Facebook, and I went to research his Facebook. He had some bad content on Qmedia. Then I find him start to do standup comedy. He tried in 2020, alone.
有人发给我他的Facebook，我研究了他的主页。他在Qmedia上有一些糟糕的内容。然后我发现他开始做脱口秀了。他在2020年尝试过，独自一人。
How do you start to do standup comedy on your own?
你怎么开始独自做脱口秀的？
[LAUGHS] I don't know. I don't know.
[笑] 我不知道。我不知道。
You just got up in the bar and--
你只是在酒吧里走上去然后——
Actually, actually, this is a very good one. I don't know if I told the guys of it. Kamal, my friend, we were having a drink in Mad Monkey Pub. So we were talking, and I don't know. I'm just saying stories and something like this. He started to laugh very hard. So he called Bisan, the owner of that place, and told her that I should start doing standup comedy at her venue. She refused, of course. And--
实际上，这是一个很好的段子。我不知道有没有跟伙计们讲过。我的朋友卡马尔，我们在Mad Monkey酒吧喝酒。我们聊着天，我不知道，我讲了一些故事之类的。他开始大笑。所以他给酒吧老板比桑（Bisan）打电话，告诉她我应该在她的店里表演脱口秀。她当然拒绝了。然后——
But then, a week or so later, the owner of the bar changed her mind. Malke's friend called and told him.
但一周后，酒吧老板改变了主意。马尔克的朋友给他打了电话告诉他。
And that was just because you're a funny guy, and people thought--
那是因为你是个有趣的人，大家觉得——
That's it. I don't know shit about standup at that time. Like, I'm coming from NGOs and bank background, you know?
就是这样。那时候我对脱口秀一窍不通。我当时来自非政府组织和银行背景，你知道吗？
So you worked in a bank, but you told jokes to your friends, and your friends were like--
所以你在银行工作，但你给朋友讲笑话，你的朋友们觉得——
Yes, yes, yes, yes. Most of my jokes come from that. I'm a good roaster at-- [CHUCKLES] I was at the bank, so--
是的，是的，是的。我大部分笑话都来自那儿。我很会调侃，在银行的时候，我——[轻笑]
And how did it go at Mad Monkey, your first gig?
那你在Mad Monkey的第一次表演怎么样？
Shit. Shit, shit, man. Pure shit. It's the purest shit you've ever seen in your life.
狗屎。狗屎，狗屎，伙计。纯粹的狗屎。你这辈子见过的最纯粹的狗屎。
Did people laugh?
人们笑了吗？
The people were sick, [LAUGHS] not laugh. They told Bisan, come on, turn on the music on now. [LAUGHS]
人们那是恶心，[笑] 不是笑。他们告诉比桑：“得了，赶紧把音乐放上吧。”[笑]
Malke had decided to quit the bank, tired of counting other people's money. And out of the blue, Sharief called him to invite him to a standup workshop he was hosting.
马尔克决定辞掉银行的工作，厌倦了清点别人的钱。突然间，沙里夫打电话邀请他参加一个脱口秀研讨会。
At the same day, man, at the same day, 2:00 PM, I signed that paper. 4:00 PM, Sharief called me, at the same day.
就在那天，伙计，就在那天下午2点，我签了辞职书。下午4点，沙里夫就给我打了电话。
And I remember when I called, he said I cannot come at this time.
我记得他打电话时，他说他那时候没法来。
This is the sheikh.
这是谢赫打来的。
Oh, the sheikh is calling Malke now.
噢，谢赫现在正给马尔克打电话。
Hello? [SPEAKING ARABIC]
喂？[讲阿拉伯语]
Malke answers the phone. Sharief paces the room, smoking and listening carefully. The call lasts about 15 minutes.
马尔克接了电话。沙里夫在房间里踱步，抽着烟仔细听着。电话持续了大约15分钟。
Alla rasi Sukran ilak, shukran. Alla rasi, shukran.
好的，谢谢你，谢谢。好的，谢谢。
[LINE BEEPING]
[电话断开声]
Oh, my God. [LAUGHS]
噢，天哪。[笑]
So what just happened, Malke?
刚才发生了什么，马尔克？
Oh, my god. Man, this is insane. 15 minutes on the phone just to talk-- just to say that you are not allowed to do your standup in Hama, OK? After this call, he will reconsider the things.
噢，天哪。伙计，这太疯狂了。在电话里聊了15分钟，仅仅是为了说你不能在哈马演出了，对吧？这个电话之后，他会重新考虑这些事。
What the sheikh said in the call was that he didn't know who canceled the show, but he understood why someone would cancel it. He'd actually seen their set in Muhardah a few months back, and he thought some of the content was inappropriate. And certainly, it would be for Hama, but not because of anything to do with LGBTQ material.
谢赫在电话里说的是，他不知道是谁取消的演出，但他理解为什么会有人取消它。他几个月前在穆哈尔达（Muhardah）看过他们的演出，他认为有些内容不合适。在哈马当然更不合适，但原因与LGBTQ内容无关。
So what were the kind of things he was saying to you?
那他跟你说的是什么样的话？
[LAUGHS] Man, this is insane. He told me that you can't say your material in Hama because it's offensive to the family values. Because we are talking about our parents.
[笑] 伙计，这太疯狂了。他告诉我，你不能在哈马表演，因为这冒犯了家庭价值观。因为我们在讲我们的父母。
So he felt that, oh, they are breaking the bonds between the families. They are affecting the people that will watch these kind of shows, that we are a threat. That's how we-- we are a threat to the family, you know? We are a threat to the family values.
所以他觉得，噢，他们在破坏家庭纽带。他们正在影响会看这种演出的人，觉得我们是个威胁。这就是我们——我们是对家庭的威胁，你知道吗？我们是对家庭价值观的威胁。
This is much more insane than the LGBTQ support thing, man. This is really new, man. This is really new. All of us have jokes on our parents, man. Everybody! This is insane.
这比那个LGBTQ支持的事情疯狂多了，伙计。这真是新鲜事。我们所有人都有关于父母的笑话，伙计。每个人！这太疯狂了。
It's my dad, man. It's my dad. If I can't speak on my dad, what else should I speak of? For what should I speak? This is my family. This is my culture.
那是我爸爸，伙计。如果我不能说我爸爸，那我还能说什么？我该为什么而说？这是我的家庭。这是我的文化。
This is we are doing standup comedy for the sheikh, not for the people, you know? This is how things are now going. The first three months, we had freedom.
这就是我们为谢赫做脱口秀，而不是为人民做脱口秀，你知道吗？事情现在就是这样发展的。前三个月，我们拥有自由。
Yeah. What was that like?
是的。那是什么感觉？
It was amazing. It's like coming from dark to the light. Then we are slowly closing the window, now slowly closing the door, slowly closing the curtains. This is bad. This is bad.
太棒了。就像是从黑暗走向光明。然后我们正在慢慢关闭窗户，现在慢慢关上门，慢慢拉上窗帘。这很糟糕。这很糟糕。
It's like, it's better if I never had it.
就像是，如果我从来没有拥有过它，会更好。
Yes.
是的。
Wow.
哇。
You know?
你知道吗？
Wow.
哇。
Oh, shit. Here we go again, you know? Oh, shit. Here we go, another Assad regime.
噢，该死。又来了，你知道吗？噢，该死。又一个阿萨德政权要来了。
On the call, Malke told the sheikh they wanted to perform in Hama to show that Hama isn't just some strict and conservative city where nothing happens. The sheikh said he'd look into it and get back to them with a final answer soon.
电话里，马尔克告诉谢赫，他们想在哈马演出是为了证明哈马不仅仅是个死气沉沉、没什么事发生的保守城市。谢赫说他会调查一下，很快会给他们最终答复。
So he's going to call back in a few hours with his decision?
所以他几个小时后会回电话告诉你决定？
I think he will call the brothers.
我想他会去联系那些兄弟们。
The brothers is Malke's sardonic way of referring to the Islamist officials now running things.
“兄弟们”是马尔克用来讽刺现在掌权的伊斯兰官员的说法。
They will call the brotherhood. He will call them and will have their advice.
他们会去联系兄弟会。他会打电话给他们，听取他们的建议。
The next day, we hit the road again.
第二天，我们再次出发。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[讲阿拉伯语]
--piling into a bright yellow van with stickers lining the sides saying "Styria" in the font of Grand Theft Auto. Malke is driving. Sharief sits behind him. There's so much equipment in the back that Malke can't see out the rear window. It's about three hours to Salamiyeh, stop 6 on the tour, depending on checkpoints.
我们挤进一辆亮黄色的面包车，侧面贴着写有“Styria”字样的贴纸，用的是《侠盗猎车手》（GTA）的字体。马尔克在开车。沙里夫坐在他后面。后面塞满了设备，马尔克看不见后窗。距离巡演第6站萨拉米耶（Salamiyeh）大约三个小时路程，取决于检查站的情况。
What's the latest with the sheikh?
谢赫那边有什么最新消息？
Sharief send me a screenshot that he is pushing also in Muhardah.
沙里夫发给我一张截图，说他也在推动穆哈尔达取消演出。
To stop you?
阻止你们？
Yes.
是的。
Muhardah is the show tomorrow night. The sheikh is now saying that show might be canceled as well.
穆哈尔达是明晚的演出。谢赫现在说那场演出也可能被取消。
I think a few hours, I'm going to make some phone calls to understand what the hell is going on.
我觉得过几个小时，我会打几个电话去弄清楚到底在搞什么鬼。
And what's your strategy with the sheikh? How are you going to convince him or control him or influence him?
那你对付谢赫的策略是什么？你打算怎么说服、控制或影响他？
He's going to turn to Islam. [LAUGHS]
他要皈依伊斯兰教了。[笑]
You're going to convert to Islam?
你打算皈依伊斯兰教？
I hope I don't have to. Because if the sheikh didn't kill me, my parents will. So I'm dead either here or there.
我希望我不必那样做。因为如果谢赫不杀我，我父母也会杀了我。所以无论哪边我都死定了。
[SPEAKING ARABIC] I told him we will not stop. So if they want to stop, let them stop us khalas. If it's going to go to jail, please take me to jail. I miss it.
[讲阿拉伯语] 我告诉他我们不会停下的。所以如果他们想阻止，就让他们来阻止吧，没关系（khalas）。如果这会进监狱，请把我带进监狱。我怀念那里了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
And with all this drama, do you want to perform in Hama?
带着所有这些戏剧性的事情，你还想在哈马表演吗？
Yes. Our show is sold out in Hama. Man, there is 200 people right now. The only entertainment they have here is us so far, besides killing each other, you know? So we are a must, not a need.
是的。我们的票在哈马卖光了。伙计，现在有200人。到目前为止，除了互相杀戮，他们在这里唯一的娱乐就是我们。所以我们是必须，而不是需要。
A few minutes later, still on the road to Salamiyeh, Malke gets a text.
几分钟后，在前往萨拉米耶的路上，马尔克收到了短信。
The sheikh just texted me that not going to be a show in Hama. This is final decision.
谢赫刚给我发信息说哈马那边不会有演出了。这是最终决定。
So what are you going to do?
那你打算怎么办？
We're going to tell the people in Hama to come to our show in Muhardah.
我们要告诉哈马的人来我们穆哈尔达的演出。
Are you going to tell them why?
你会告诉他们原因吗？
Yes, of course I'm going to tell them why.
是的，我当然会告诉他们为什么。
For them, this isn't over. They could let it go, but Malke won't. They decide to test the limits another way-- make it public, and see who's stronger right now, the government or the people. They want to use public opinion to force them to reinstate the show.
对他们来说，这还没结束。他们可以放手，但马尔克不干。他们决定以另一种方式试探底线——将其公开，看看现在谁更有力量，政府还是人民。他们想利用舆论迫使政府恢复演出。
The Styria comedians are all pretty young. They think in TikTok and Instagram. They believe a big enough online following will give them protection from government officials trying to silence them. They have hundreds of thousands of followers on Instagram.
Styria的喜剧演员都很年轻。他们用TikTok和Instagram思考。他们相信足够多的在线关注会给他们提供保护，防止政府官员压制他们。他们在Instagram上有几十万粉丝。
Syria's revolutionaries also used social media to rise to power. But now that they run things, they fear it, fear posts that inflame sectarian tempers, fear looking weak. At the same time, they don't want to look like the old regime, repressive and censoring in public. So they pressure quietly, in private, and the comedians answer loudly online.
叙利亚的革命者们也曾利用社交媒体夺取政权。但现在他们掌权了，他们害怕这些，害怕煽动宗派情绪的帖子，害怕看起来软弱。与此同时，他们不想看起来像旧政权，在公共场合实行高压和审查。所以他们悄悄施压，而喜剧演员们则在网上大声回击。
Malke and Sharief go on the offensive. They post that the Hama show is canceled, and tell Hama fans to come to Muhardah instead. They'll add seats. They'll arrange buses. They're trying to turn the followers into force.
马尔克和沙里夫发起进攻。他们发布了哈马演出取消的消息，并告诉粉丝们改去穆哈尔达。他们会增加座位，安排巴士。他们正试图将粉丝转化成一股力量。
It's a respectful post, not calling anyone out. But they figure their fans will understand why it was canceled, get pissed off, and put pressure on the government. But then one of the other comedians, Abo Azez, goes rogue on his personal Instagram account.
这是一个礼貌的帖子，没有指名道姓。但他们认为粉丝会明白为什么被取消，感到愤怒，并向政府施压。但随后，另一位喜剧演员阿博·阿泽兹（Abo Azez）在他的个人Instagram上“叛变”了。
So Azez, you know him. Azez is much--
阿泽兹，你知道他。阿泽兹是很——
Crazy, man.
疯狂，伙计。
--crazy. He's not diplomatic, you know? He's not diplomatic. He--
——疯狂的。他不圆滑，你知道吗？他不圆滑。他——
He's so funny. He's funny. [LAUGHS]
他太搞笑了。他很有趣。[笑]
Very stupid and very--
非常愚蠢，也非常——
Very Abo Azez.
非常有阿博·阿泽兹的风格。
--very Abo Azez, you know?
——非常阿博·阿泽兹，你知道吗？
On Instagram, Abo Azez goes off.
在Instagram上，阿博·阿泽兹彻底爆发了。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[讲阿拉伯语]
He rants about the secretariat for Political Affairs in Hama, says they accused the troupe of LGBTQ content and of being a threat to family values. He blames them for canceling Hama. We're back to how we were before, he says, which sounds pretty mild, but he's comparing the new government to the old regime, which is dangerous.
他咆哮着哈马的政治事务秘书处，说他们指责剧团有LGBTQ内容，说他们是对家庭价值观的威胁。他指责他们取消了哈马的演出。他说，我们回到了过去，听起来很温和，但他把新政府比作旧政权，这很危险。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[讲阿拉伯语]
Abo Azez has nearly 300,000 followers. Him posting online left some in the group nervous, but excited Malke and Sharief. The comments start right away, angry at the government.
阿博·阿泽兹有近30万粉丝。他在网上的发帖让团队里的一些人感到紧张，但让马尔克和沙里夫感到兴奋。评论区立刻炸开了锅，大家对政府感到愤怒。
Word gets back. Someone from Political Affairs calls Abo Azez. Political Affairs also contacts the sheikh. The sheikh calls Malke. Malke doesn't pick up, so the sheikh follows with a text.
消息传开了。政治事务部门的人打电话给阿博·阿泽兹。政治事务部门也联系了谢赫。谢赫打电话给马尔克。马尔克没接，谢赫随后发了短信。
I didn't answer. I will let him, khalas. We have canceled this show. Then when--
我没接。随他去吧，没关系。我们已经取消了演出。然后当——
Within an hour, answer him.
一小时内，回答他。
I think--
我想——
In an hour, answer him.
一小时内，回答他。
I think I will tell-- no, leave him in half an hour. Let things boil up, you know? So I leave him now. I think an hour later or maybe in the evening, they will tell us, do your show in Hama.
我想我会告诉——不，再晾他半小时。让事情发酵一下，你知道吗？所以现在先不管他。我想一小时后或者晚上，他们会告诉我们：在哈马表演吧。
Some members of the group are worried by the strategy, wishing they had been consulted first. But almost as quickly as they stir up the online shitstorm, Sharief gets a text from the Hama venue owner.
团队里的一些成员对这个策略感到担心，希望先和他们商量一下。但就在他们搅起网上舆论风暴的时候，沙里夫收到了哈马场地老板的短信。
No matter what, he won't let them use the venue. It's not worth it to him. He's scared of a visit from the authorities-- a fine, a lost license, a knock on the door, or worse, an attack.
无论如何，他都不会让他们使用场地。对他来说不值得。他害怕当局的造访——罚款、吊销执照、敲门，或者更糟的攻击。
Malke and Sharief have officially lost the battle for Hama. They're still trying to direct people to come to the Muhardah show instead, but now that might be canceled as well. They play Salamiyeh that night.
马尔克和沙里夫正式输掉了哈马之战。他们仍然试图引导人们去穆哈尔达看演出，但现在那场可能也会被取消。那天晚上，他们在萨拉米耶完成了演出。
[SPEAKING ARABIC] Wow.
[讲阿拉伯语] 哇。
[APPLAUSE, CHEERING]
[掌声，欢呼]
Hey.
嘿。
It goes great-- standing ovation.
效果很好——起立鼓掌。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[讲阿拉伯语]
[CHEERING, APPLAUSE]
[欢呼，掌声]
Then, after the show, a call from the Ministry of Media. This guy is furious about Abo Azez's post and tries to stop the show they've just finished.
然后，演出结束后，接到了媒体部的电话。那家伙对阿博·阿泽兹的帖子怒不可遏，试图阻止他们刚完成的那场演出。
Are you worried they're going to stop your other shows?
你担心他们会阻止你其他的演出吗？
Now, tomorrow, it's going to be Muhardah. No, they are not going to come to Muhardah. Maybe they will do some phone calls, and that's it. It's now our move. On the chessboard, it's now our move. We have the media. We have the people. They have weapons.
现在，明天就是穆哈尔达。不，他们不会来穆哈尔达。也许他们会打几个电话，就这样。现在轮到我们出招了。在棋盘上，现在轮到我们移动。我们有媒体。我们有人民。他们有武器。
Yes. So Abo Azez is a very powerful chess piece.
是的。所以阿博·阿泽兹是一颗非常有力的棋子。
Yeah. No, he's very Tahish, we call it, that the one who-- like a tank, you know? This is the first who come into the battle.
是的。不，他非常“Tahish”，我们称之为像坦克一样的人，你知道吗？这是第一个冲入战场的人。
Oh, OK.
哦，好的。
And then people come, like snipers and military. And everything is a war. Yeah, in Syria, everything is a war. Even the art is a war, yanni.
然后人们跟随，像狙击手和军队一样。一切都是战争。是的，在叙利亚，一切都是战争。连艺术都是战争，雅尼。
Malke isn't worried about the show in Muhardah. He tells me it's a Christian town, so the sheikh has no power there.
马尔克不担心穆哈尔达的演出。他告诉我那是个基督教城镇，所以谢赫在那里没有权力。
Ayman Oghanna. Coming up, "Muhardah, She Wrote." The comedy show moves on to Muhardah. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
我是艾曼·奥汉纳。接下来，“穆哈尔达，她写道。”喜剧表演转移到穆哈尔达。一分钟后回到芝加哥公共广播电台，继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, a Christian and a Muslim walk into a bar. We pick up with reporter Ayman Oghanna and the comedians of Styria on their tour of the country for Act Three, an act we're calling, "Is This Thing On?"
这里是《This American Life》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目，一个基督徒和一个穆斯林走进了一家酒吧。我们要继续跟随记者艾曼·奥汉纳和Styria的喜剧演员们进行全国巡演，进入第三幕，我们称这一幕为“那个东西在开着吗？”（Is This Thing On?）
[ARABIC CHATTER]
[阿拉伯语聊天]
It's morning. We're back in the van, heading from Salamiyeh to Muhardah, a show they hope will still happen and where a busload of fans from Hama will join them. We pass a car with a rocket launcher on the roof.
早上。我们回到面包车里，前往穆哈尔达，他们希望那场演出还能照常进行，而且会有整整一车从哈马来的粉丝加入。我们经过一辆车顶装有火箭发射器的汽车。
This is--
那是——
A rocket launcher, man, on a Humvee. [LAUGHS]
一个火箭发射器，伙计，装在悍马上。[笑]
Monuments of Syria's bloody war still dot the roads. We see bombed-out buildings and burnt-out cars on the way. We have a system for checkpoints. Malke flashes a big smile, and I hide my recording equipment under a coat.
叙利亚血腥战争的纪念碑仍然散布在道路两旁。路上我们看到了被炸毁的建筑物和烧毁的汽车。我们有一套过检查站的系统。马尔克露出大大的笑容，我把录音设备藏在大衣下面。
Checkpoint for--
检查站——
OK, checkpoint. I need to take my headphones off.
好的，检查站。我得摘下耳机。
Malke is flying high this morning. We're leaving the more conservative Sunni Muslim areas and heading to a Christian town. Christians are a minority in Syria, about 10% before the war. And Malke is Christian. He's relaxed, in shorts, grinning as he drives.
马尔克今天早上情绪高昂。我们正在离开更保守的逊尼派穆斯林地区，前往一个基督教城镇。基督徒是叙利亚的少数群体，战前占10%左右。而马尔克是基督徒。他很放松，穿着短裤，开着车咧嘴笑着。
So this is Muhardah?
所以这就是穆哈尔达？
Yes, this is Muhardah. Welcome to the Christian people! Fuck you, Sharief!
是的，这是穆哈尔达。欢迎来到基督徒的土地！去你的，沙里夫！
I'm with you. [SPEAKING ARABIC]
我和你一起。[讲阿拉伯语]
Woo! Hallelujah! Hallelujah. Now we are safe. Now we are safe from HTS--
呜！哈利路亚！哈利路亚。现在我们安全了。现在我们不用担心HTS——
Why?
为什么？
--and all the governments. This is a Christian country. Here, this is a Christian land. No Muslim is allowed to go here. Ayman, are you Christian?
——和所有政府了。这是基督教国家。这里，这是基督教土地。没有穆斯林被允许进入这里。艾曼，你是基督徒吗？
I am.
我是。
Yes. Welcome home.
是的。欢迎回家。
We get into town, go into a cafe.
我们进入小镇，走进一家咖啡馆。
Malke.
马尔克。
Yeah.
怎么了？
Have you heard from anyone who's from Hama who's taking the bus tonight?
你有没有收到来自哈马的人今晚要坐巴士过来的消息？
I don't know, but I think there is 40, 50 people, something like this. I feel that when the evening come, it will be 60 or I think 60, 70, something like this. I hope it's going to be good.
我不知道，但我觉得大概有40、50人吧。我觉得晚上到了之后，会变成60或者我觉得60、70人左右。希望演出会很棒。
This is where we drink a lot. This is the place. They are very, very, very generous, very generous here. Because they are Christian.
这里是我们喝酒的地方。这是那个地方。他们非常、非常、非常慷慨，非常慷慨。因为他们是基督徒。
Everyone is happy, smiling. They order pizza.
每个人都很开心，微笑着。他们点了披萨。
(SINGING) I go back to us
(唱歌) 我回到我们这儿
[BACKGROUND CHATTER]
[背景聊天]
[SPEAKING ARABIC] I love this song.
[讲阿拉伯语] 我喜欢这首歌。
But an hour later, the mood changes. Malke looks distressed. He has changed back into jeans, as conservative Syrians frown upon men wearing shorts. We get back into the car with the venue owner for the show tonight.
但一小时后，气氛变了。马尔克看起来很苦恼。他换回了牛仔裤，因为保守的叙利亚人不喜欢男人穿短裤。我们和今晚的场地老板一起回到车里。
Hey, Malke, tell me exactly what's happening.
嘿，马尔克，告诉到底发生了什么。
Oh, a lot happening. A lot. Let me think about it first. Then I will talk to you just to--
噢，发生了很多事。很多。让我想想先。然后我再告诉你，为了——
The venue owner has gotten a call from the local government in Muhardah asking him to come in for a meeting. We drive to the local municipal building. I walk with Malke, but get stopped at the stairwell, while Malke and the venue owner go into an office. A few minutes later, Malke comes back and says I can come in.
场地老板接到了穆哈尔达当地政府的电话，要求他去开会。我们开车去当地市政大楼。我和马尔克走进去，但在楼梯间被拦住了，而马尔克和场地老板进了一个办公室。几分钟后，马尔克回来，说我可以进去了。
[SPEAKING ARABIC] Plus this, give it to the boys outside.
[讲阿拉伯语] 加上这个，给外面的伙计们。
Give what? The recorder?
给什么？录音机？
Yes, the recording and the headset.
是的，录音和耳机。
OK, sure. I can listen--
好的，没问题。我可以听——
And your bag also.
还有你的包。
OK.
好的。
They take my bag, the recorder, everyone's phones. There are two government men inside the office-- beards, shaved mustaches, military outfits. They look straight out of central casting.
他们拿走了我的包、录音机和所有人的手机。办公室里有两名政府人员——留着胡子，刮得干干净净的嘴唇，穿着军装。他们看起来就像是从选角中心直接走出来的。
But they're polite. One asks if we want coffee. Another then brings glass cups of Nescafe 3-in-1, a sugary instant coffee ubiquitous across the Middle East.
但他们很有礼貌。一个人问我们是否要咖啡。另一个随后端来了玻璃杯装的Nescafe 3合1，这在中东随处可见的甜味速溶咖啡。
My translator waits downstairs, so I don't follow everything. But one of the government guys says he recognizes me. I'd covered the Syrian war, and we had been in the same towns in Idlib province. Malke later jokes that 10 years ago, they may have kidnapped me. It's a different country to report in now.
我的翻译在楼下等，所以我没听懂全部。但其中一个政府人员说他认出我了。我曾报道过叙利亚战争，我们在伊德利卜省的同一个城镇待过。马尔克后来开玩笑说，10年前，他们可能已经把我绑架了。现在这是一个不同的报道环境。
I watch the room. The older one sits behind a desk, does most of the talking. Eventually, another brings in a piece of paper and beckons the venue owner to come to him. The owner is nervous and doesn't hesitate to sign it. Malke explained to me what was going on afterwards.
我观察着房间。年长的那位坐在办公桌后，大部分话由他说。最终，另一个人拿进一张纸，示意场地老板过来。老板很紧张，毫不犹豫地签了字。马尔克事后解释了发生了什么。
They were very angry. So they told us that we can't do our show in Muhardah because there is no permission from Hama Political Affairs. So now, we are making some phone calls to have that permission. I hope to have it, yanni.
他们非常生气。他们告诉我们，我们不能在穆哈尔达演出了，因为没有哈马政治事务处的许可。所以现在，我们正在打电话寻求那种许可。我希望能拿到，雅尼。
Malke had miscalculated. He figured that because Muhardah is a Christian town, the sheikh and the local Hama government wouldn't have reach here. But instead, the local politicians in Muhardah are telling them, if they want to do tonight's show in Muhardah, they need to get permission from the sheikh and the other bureaucrats in Hama, the ones they started a battle with yesterday, the ones now threatening a libel case.
马尔克失算了。他以为穆哈尔达是基督教城镇，谢赫和哈马当地政府管不到这儿。但相反，穆哈尔达的当地政客告诉他们，如果想在今晚的穆哈尔达表演，必须拿到谢赫和哈马其他官僚的许可，也就是昨天他们爆发争吵的那帮人，现在正威胁要起诉诽谤的那帮人。
What was it they made the owner sign?
他们让老板签了什么？
Obligation.
义务书。
Saying? He promises--
上面写着？他承诺——
Saying that he promises that he won't let us do the show without written permission from their office.
上面写着他承诺，没有他们办公室的书面许可，绝不让我们举办演出。
Has this ever happened before to you?
以前发生过这种事吗？
No. No.
没有。没有。
When you arrived in Muhardah, you were like, we're free now and no one can stop us. So how do you feel now?
当你到达穆哈尔达时，你还说，我们自由了，没人能阻止我们。所以你现在感觉如何？
Shit. Shit. Shit. They have more power than I thought here. This is dangerous.
狗屎。狗屎。狗屎。他们的权力比我想象的要大。这很危险。
Yesterday, they were very upset with us doing the show in Salamiyeh. So now, they will prevent us from doing the show here. I don't know what things will happen the next few hours.
昨天，他们对我们在萨拉米耶的演出很不爽。所以现在，他们要阻止我们在这里演出了。我不知道接下来几个小时会发生什么。
Their only path tonight is persistence. If they can get permission from the Hama officials Abo Azez just insulted, they can still go on in Muhardah. It's 3:15 PM. The show is at 7:00. It's sold out. Buses of fans are supposed to come from Hama.
他们今晚唯一的路就是坚持。如果能从阿博·阿泽兹刚才冒犯过的哈马官员那里得到许可，他们还是可以在穆哈尔达演出。现在是下午3点15分。演出在7点开始。票已经售罄。载着粉丝的巴士本来应该从哈马过来。
We get in the car-- me, Malke, and the venue owner-- and head towards Hama to try to talk to the politicians and see if there's any way to save tonight's show in Muhardah. 10 minutes out, the venue owner answers his phone. I can't tell what the call is about, but he goes quiet, then asks us to turn back. We head back to Muhardah, to the same cafe. Malke smokes a cigarette on the street outside, defeated.
我们上车——我和马尔克还有场地老板——前往哈马，试图和政客们谈谈，看看有没有办法挽救今晚的演出。开出10分钟，场地老板接了电话。我听不出电话内容，但他安静下来，然后让我们掉头。我们返回穆哈尔达，回到那家咖啡馆。马尔克在街上抽烟，显得很颓废。
Why did we turn back from Hama?
为什么我们要从哈马掉头回来？
Because they started to hurt him now. They started to hurt him. I'm sorry, man, I have to stop this because I'm very tired now.
因为他们开始伤害他了。他们开始伤害他。对不起，伙计，我必须停下来，因为我现在太累了。
Malke later told me that the venue owner got a call from his dad. The government is also putting pressure on him, real enough pressure that he got scared and didn't want to cause more trouble by heading to Hama.
马尔克后来告诉我，场地老板接到了他父亲的电话。政府也在给他施压，那种真实的压力让他害怕了，不想因为去哈马而惹出更多麻烦。
To make matters worse, on the way back, Malke also gets a call. First, they've been told they needed permission from the Political Affairs Office in Hama to run the Muhardah show. Now, the bar moves even farther away from them. Officials are now saying they need three permissions-- from Political Affairs and also from the Ministries of Tourism and Culture. And the guy running the local office of the Ministry of Culture is the sheikh.
更糟糕的是，回去的路上，马尔克又接到了电话。起初，他们被告知需要哈马政治事务处的许可才能在穆哈尔达演出。现在，门槛又被进一步拉高了。官员们现在说他们需要三份许可——分别来自政治事务处、旅游部和文化部。而负责哈马文化部当地办公室的人，就是谢赫。
All because of what? What have you guys said or done?
这一切都是因为什么？你们做了什么或说了什么？
This is because of jokes. Yes, this is because of jokes. I can't think of a place shittier than here, you know? I hate this country. I swear to God, I hate it from the bottom of my heart. This is a message that you don't play with us.
这是因为那些笑话。是的，是因为笑话。我想不出比这里更烂的地方了，你知道吗？我恨这个国家。我向真主发誓，我打心底里恨它。这是一个信息：别跟我们玩花样。
They think you're troublemakers.
他们觉得你们是惹祸精。
Yes, yes. For them. This is insane. This is insane.
是的，是的。对他们来说。这太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。
I'm tired now, mentally and physically tired. I'm using all my connections. And when I do, when I put 9 on the table, they put 10. I put 10, a guy, they put a queen. I put a king, they put an ace. So it's always fuck.
我现在很累，精神和身体都很疲惫。我动用了我所有的关系。每当我把9放到桌面上，他们就拿出10。我出10，他们出皇后。我出国王，他们出A。所以总是该死的失败。
We're going to wait one more hour, and then we will know what to do. We need an hour, I think. [EXHALES]
我们要再等一个小时，然后我们就知道该怎么办了。我想我们需要一个小时。[呼气]
Man, I don't know what to do. I don't want it to be a fight. I want to be in agreement.
伙计，我不知道该怎么办。我不想这变成一场斗争。我想要达成协议。
Well, you want to be a comedian, and you can't do that.
嗯，你想成为脱口秀演员，但你做不到。
[LAUGHS] This is the last thing I think of right now, actually. I swear to God, this is the last thing I think of.
[笑] 这实际上是我现在想到的最后一件事。我向上帝发誓，这是我最后一件事会想的。
Malke hasn't eaten since yesterday. He's running on coffee and cigarettes. He's getting impatient with my questions. He and the other comedians start talking in Arabic around a crowded table. The conversation is heated.
马尔克从昨天起就没吃东西。他全靠咖啡和烟支撑。他对我问的问题越来越没耐心。他和另一名喜剧演员开始在那张拥挤的桌子旁用阿拉伯语争论起来。对话很激烈。
[ARGUING IN ARABIC]
[阿拉伯语争论]
I find Sharief outside the cafe, emotional.
我在咖啡馆外找到了沙里夫，情绪很激动。
OK, man, I can see you have tears in your eyes. You're upset.
好的，伙计，我能看出你眼里含着泪水。你很难过。
Walla bro, I feel sad, you know? I'm sad because the people who got influence now, they're using Bashar ways and Bashar law to stop us from making people have some fun.
伙计，我感到难过，你知道吗？我难过是因为现在那些有影响力的人，他们正在使用巴沙尔的方式和巴沙尔的法律来阻止我们给人们带去快乐。
Yeah, how is freedom of expression working out for you in Syria now?
是啊，叙利亚现在的言论自由感觉如何？
It's not working at all. It's not working. And the thing are working is not freedom, are who have the bigger balls.
根本没用。根本没用。现在有用的不是自由，而是谁的胆子更大。
And how are the other guys taking the news?
其他伙计们对这个消息有什么反应？
Some of them are scared. Some of them-- Qassim imagine he's scared. He's a doctor in the university. He's scared that might reach him in a way that they will let him go from the university.
有些人很害怕。有些人——想想卡西姆（Qassim），他很害怕。他是大学教授，他害怕这可能会以某种方式波及到他，让他失去教职。
Other want to make money. Other want to make fame. Other want to make the project continue. It's their own right to feel and do whatever they want. But for me, I push by myself. Yeah. So let's see.
其他人想赚钱，想出名。其他人想让这个项目继续下去。他们有权感受并做任何他们想做的事。但对我来说，我独自坚持。是的。所以让我们看看吧。
But soon after this conversation, they call it. Malke can't secure the three permissions in time, so they're forced to cancel just three hours before showtime. They post on Styria's Instagram that the show's off due to unforeseen circumstances and tell people they'll refund tickets. Now they're worried the government is also going to cancel their show in Aleppo, which is two days away.
但在这次谈话后不久，他们决定放弃了。马尔克没能在开演前筹齐三份许可，所以被迫在开演前三小时取消了演出。他们在Styria的Instagram上发帖说演出因不可抗力取消，并告诉人们他们会退票。现在他们担心政府也会取消两天后的阿勒颇演出。
I find them hours later in Sharief's hotel room. One of the other comedians is giving Sharief a massage.
几小时后，我在沙里夫的酒店房间里找到了他们。另一名喜剧演员正在给沙里夫按摩。
So I see you guys are promoting LGBTQ.
所以我看到你们在宣扬同性恋权利了。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
That night, instead of doing their show, they get drunk and dance until 3:00 in the morning.
那天晚上，他们没有演出，而是喝得大醉，跳舞跳到凌晨3点。
The next day, the politicians in Hama want Abo Azez to bend the knee, apologize. Malke says he won't make Abo Azez do that alone. We get in the car to Hama to meet Abo Azez, who's already driven up from Damascus. Malke is anxious and frustrated.
第二天，哈马的政客想让阿博·阿泽兹“下跪”，道歉。马尔克说他不会让阿博·阿泽兹独自一人承担。我们开车去哈马见从大马士革赶来的阿博·阿泽兹。马尔克焦虑且沮丧。
I didn't sleep well, actually.
其实我没睡好。
So what are you hoping? You're going to see these guys, and what?
所以你希望什么？你要去见这些人，然后呢？
To end this madness, man. To end this madness. I think we've been in this case three days now.
结束这一切疯狂，伙计。结束这场疯狂。我想这事我们都纠缠三天了。
Yeah.
是啊。
The fuck is this, man? Three days? Three days for a fucking comedy show?
这到底是什么，伙计？三天？一场该死的脱口秀演了三天？
They are wrong, OK? They are the political affair. They are wrong. But we didn't play well. When we play, we gave them our neck.
他们错了，好吗？他们是政治事务部门。他们错了。但我们也没做好。当我们表演时，我们把脖子递给了他们。
We get to the Political Affairs Office and inside a large, drab, concrete government building. At the door, the security guard says they're expecting us, and Malke tightens.
我们到了政治事务办公室，里面是一个巨大、灰暗、混凝土结构的政府大楼。门口，保安说他们正在等我们，马尔克紧绷了起来。
Up a dim stairwell to a large office, three suited officials sit in a row like judges facing out. One of them is the infamous sheikh. We're shown to chairs by their side. Abo Azez is already there. Malke tells me to put my recorder outside again.
穿过暗淡的楼梯间来到一个大办公室，三名穿着西装的官员像法官一样坐成一排。其中一个就是臭名昭著的谢赫。我们在他们旁边坐下。阿博·阿泽兹已经在那里了。马尔克叫我把录音机放出去。
Please, we're going to take this outside. Then we're going to talk.
求你了，我们把它拿出去。然后我们再谈。
All right.
好的。
The meeting begins. It's all in Arabic, but my translator is there and takes notes.
会议开始了。全程用阿拉伯语，但我的翻译在场并做着笔记。
The government officials are stern and condescending. Their age and authority looms over Abo Azez and Malke. They have the room.
政府官员严肃而居高临下。他们的年龄和权威笼罩着阿博·阿泽兹和马尔克。这房间是他们的主场。
The men from Political Affairs tell the comedians they were insulted by Abo Azez's post, that it's unacceptable to compare them to the Assad regime. They ask Abo Azez how many people saw his post. He says 47,000 and apologizes, says what he did was wrong.
来自政治事务部门的人告诉喜剧演员，阿博·阿泽兹的帖子侮辱了他们，将他们与阿萨德政权相比是不可接受的。他们问阿博·阿泽兹有多少人看了他的帖子。他说47,000人，并道歉说自己做错了。
The officials say that in addition to the post being inappropriate, it wasn't true. They never canceled the show. Malke pushes back. That's what his fixer was told when he had gone to pay the fees for the show.
官员们说，除了帖子不恰当外，事实也不属实。他们从没取消演出。马尔克反击说，这是他的协调人在去缴费时被告知的。
Whatever the truth of that, the three officials do have a lot to say about the content of the shows. One of them says that he went to one of their shows a few months back, that he sat in the front row with his son. He says, I regretted bringing him, but what calmed me was that he fell asleep during the show. From the start, all your jokes were about religion, sex, and sensitive topics that threaten civil peace.
无论真相如何，这三名官员对演出内容确实有很多话要说。其中一人说他几个月前看过他们的演出，当时他和儿子坐在前排。他说：“我后悔带他去，但让我平静下来的是他在演出期间睡着了。从头到尾，你们所有的笑话都围绕着宗教、性和威胁民事和平的敏感话题。”
They remind the comedians that under Assad, they could joke about anything but politics. Now, they can joke as much as they want about politics or the government, but they can't joke about topics that could disturb the civil peace. They point to a little dance Abo Azez does at the start of his set. They say it's sexual. They say society's morals have deteriorated.
他们提醒喜剧演员，在阿萨德统治下，他们可以开任何玩笑，除了政治。现在，他们可以随意拿政治或政府开玩笑，但不能拿可能扰乱民事和平的话题开玩笑。他们指出了阿博·阿泽兹开场时跳的一段小舞，说那很色情。他们说社会道德已经堕落了。
Abo Azez apologizes a second time. He tries to break the tension with a joke. He says, there are three things I love-- Ahmad al-Sharaa, Bashar al-Assad, and sport. But the truth is, I only like two of them. You can choose whichever you like. It's a joke because Abo Azez is overweight, not a big athlete, and it's impossible to both love Sharaa and Assad.
阿博·阿泽兹第二次道歉。他试图用一个笑话打破僵局。他说：“我有三样东西最爱——艾哈迈德·沙拉、巴沙尔·阿萨德和运动。但事实是，我只喜欢其中两个。你们可以选择任何一个喜欢的。”这是一个笑话，因为阿博·阿泽兹超重，不是大运动员，而且同时喜欢沙拉和阿萨德是不可能的。
Silence. No smiles, no laughs. It's awkward. The message is clear-- this is not a joke. The meeting wraps up after an hour. Afterwards, I ask Abo Azez about it.
沉默。没有微笑，没有笑声。气氛很尴尬。信息很明确——这不是个笑话。会议一小时后结束。之后，我问阿博·阿泽兹。
Do you regret the post now?
你现在后悔发那个帖子了吗？
Yes, I regret my reaction and putting the story. Because if I do that and comparing them to the old regime, if I do that with the old regime, I will be killed or forcefully disappeared. But the new government have at least sat with me, discussed the issue with me, and they let me leave.
是的，我后悔我的反应和发帖。因为如果我这样做，并把他们比作旧政权，如果我在旧政权时期做这件事，我会被杀或者被强制失踪。但新政府至少和我坐下来，跟我讨论了这个问题，还让我离开了。
It says a lot about where Syria is now. Not the old terror, not real freedom either. The state will absolve you if you apologize, rather than make you disappear into the prison system.
这说明了叙利亚现在的处境。没有了旧时代的恐怖，也没有真正的自由。如果你道歉，国家就会赦免你，而不是让你消失在监狱系统里。
You can post. You can film. You can even argue in a room like that. But you have to bow down to authority, which, after 50 years of dictatorship, Syrians know how to do.
你可以发帖。你可以录像。你甚至可以在那种房间里争论。但你必须向权力低头，而经历了50年独裁统治的叙利亚人知道该怎么做。
It seems to me like in Syria today, everyone has tasted freedom for the first time, and they're not sure what to do with it. Even the government don't even know what to do with freedom.
在我看来，在今天的叙利亚，每个人都是第一次品尝到自由，他们不确定该拿它怎么办。甚至连政府自己都不知道该如何处理自由。
Yes. [CHUCKLES] Of course. You have said it, yanni khalas. We are learning, and they are learning.
是的。[轻笑] 当然。你说得对，没关系（khalas）。我们在学习，他们也在学习。
I spoke to the sheikh afterwards. He reiterated that he didn't cancel the show. He said his remit is cultural centers only, and the comedians are banned from the cultural centers in Hama. But anything in a private venue, he said, is outside his authority. He never told anyone to stop anything.
之后我和谢赫聊了聊。他重申他没取消演出。他说他的职权仅限于文化中心，而喜剧演员被禁止进入哈马的文化中心。但他说，任何私人场所的活动都不在他的管辖范围内。他从没告诉过任何人阻止任何事情。
He is lying, man.
他在撒谎，伙计。
I told Malke about the conversation.
我把这次对话告诉了马尔克。
He said it was a misunderstanding. He--
他说这是一个误会。他——
No. That's what they say after-- when feel the heat, you know? "I'm sorry. It's a misunderstanding." Fuck you, and fuck your misunderstanding.
不。他们感到压力时就会这么说，你知道吗？“对不起，这是一个误会。”去你的，去你的误会。
Understand well, because you are in a position you have to understand well. Any misunderstanding can lead to blood. You have to be aware of what kind of business you do.
听好了，因为你处于一个必须听明白的位置。任何误会都可能导致流血。你必须意识到你在做什么生意。
I also learned the sheikh is not actually a sheikh.
我还得知那个谢赫其实并不是谢赫。
Do you call all the politicians sheikh?
你称呼所有政客为谢赫吗？
Not all. Only the Muslim one.
不是全部。只有穆斯林政客。
We tried to figure out who canceled the show in Hama and didn't get anywhere either.
我们试着查出到底是谁取消了哈马的演出，但没查到任何结果。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[讲阿拉伯语]
The next two shows are in Aleppo. And even though Malke was worried about Aleppo from the start, the shows there are not canceled. They sell out both shows, 1,000 tickets in total.
接下来的两场演出是在阿勒颇。尽管马尔克从一开始就担心阿勒颇，但那里的演出没有取消。两场演出场场爆满，总计1,000张票。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[讲阿拉伯语]
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Malke does the joke about his dad and one about being a Christian in a mosque. Sharief tells the bra joke.
马尔克讲了他父亲的笑话，还有一个关于作为基督徒在清真寺里的段子。沙里夫讲了那个胸罩笑话。
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[讲阿拉伯语]
[LAUGHTER, APPLAUSE]
[笑声，掌声]
[SPEAKING ARABIC]
[讲阿拉伯语]
See? Malke was right. They kill in Arabic.
看到了吗？马尔克是对的。他们用阿拉伯语表演简直要了命。
Ayman Oghanna is a reporter in Damascus.
艾曼·奥汉纳是一名大马士革的记者。
Well, our program was produced today by Dana Chivvis and edited by Phia Bennin and David Kestenbaum with fact-checking by Hany Hawasly. The people who put together today's show include Michael Comite, Suzanne Gaber, Tobin Low, Katherine Rae Mondo, Stowe Nelson, Ruthie Pettito, Nadia Reiman, Ryan Rumery, Frances Swanson, Christopher Swetala, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
今天的节目由达娜·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）制作，由菲亚·贝宁（Phia Bennin）和大卫·克斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）剪辑，事实核查由哈尼·哈瓦斯利（Hany Hawasly）完成。参与制作今天节目的还有迈克尔·科米特（Michael Comite）、苏珊·加伯（Suzanne Gaber）、托宾·洛（Tobin Low）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、鲁西·佩蒂托（Ruthie Pettito）、纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）、瑞安·鲁梅里（Ryan Rumery）、弗朗西斯·斯旺森（Frances Swanson）、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）和黛安·吴（Diane Wu）。我们的总编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼（Sarah Abdurrahman）。我们的执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里（Emanuele Berry）。
Aref Al Kerz worked with Ayman in Syria. Jude Taha did translations.
阿雷夫·阿尔·凯兹（Aref Al Kerz）在叙利亚与艾曼合作。裘德·塔哈（Jude Taha）负责翻译。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. When people walk up to him on the street, before they barely get a word out, he lets them know--
我们的网站是thisamericanlife.org。《This American Life》由公共广播交换平台PRX分发给公共广播电台。像往常一样，感谢该节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。当人们在街上向他走去时，在他们几乎还没说出一句话之前，他就会告诉他们——
I'm not George Clooney.
我不是乔治·克鲁尼。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周继续带来更多《This American Life》的故事。